-Our next guest is an Emmy-
nominated actor and musician.
He stars in the series
"Big Shot"
which is streaming now
on Disney+.
He also hosts the podcast
"Snatching Sinatra" on Wondery,
which is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
John Stamos.
How you are, John?
-Hello, Seth. Nice to see you.
-It's very exciting news.
You are a new father since
the last time we saw each other.
-Yes. And I was --
We were inspired by --
You had your --
Your baby was born in the lobby
of your apartment building?
-Yes, but that was
my wife's fault.
-Yeah, we tried to have our kid
at the bowling alley,
but it was closed.
Got to -- The laundromat
was open, so we went there.
-Oh, that's great.
Yeah, you just --
Ultimately,
you got to find a place
that will make for a good
anecdote down the line.
-Is this my good --
What's the good side
that Kristen and Dax were --
-It's great. I think you're
really good. We've --
You've have always been known
as having no bad sides, John.
-Well, no.
This is my Rob Lowe side.
-Oh, yeah.
That is very Rob Lowe.
-And this is my Scott Baio side.
So you choose.
-Rob Lowe, please.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, may I just say
that I just love you.
I've been a fan of yours for
a long, long time, as you know.
But during this last
year and a half,
you've just
upped your game so much.
And it's just -- You were just
the guy to turn to.
And I appreciate
how great and funny,
and I was so happy
that you were on and leading us,
and thank you. That's all.
-Oh, well, thank you very much.
I felt incredibly lucky
to have a show like this.
And I also want to thank you,
because I think a lot of us
have turned to podcasts,
and you have a wonderful one
and a story that I did not
know anything about
that came across your desk,
I should say, in the '80s,
which was about the kidnapping
of Frank Sinatra's son.
How did you first come to know
about this story?
-Isn't it a crazy story? A lot
of people just don't even --
Didn't even know it happened.
I was, through my relationship
with the Beach Boys,
I met Jan and Dean,
the other surf rock duo.
And I was at a fair,
at the Orange County Fair,
I remember early in the '80s.
And Dean Torrence turned to me,
said, "Say, Stamos,
you produce?"
I'm like, "Yeah, sure." I didn't
know what producing was.
He said, "I loaned
the seed money to my best friend
to kidnap Frank Sinatra Jr."
I was like, "What?"
And he gave me this --
Look at this.
He said that Barry Keenan,
the mastermind who kidnapped
Sinatra Jr., wrote this in jail
and gave it to Dean,
said, "I have the rights,
if you want
to do something with it."
I didn't really know
what to do with it back then.
And a few years later,
I was like,
"Dean, what happened
to that story of your friend?"
And he said they tried to get it
made for many, many years,
but Sinatra didn't want it made.
He didn't want it talked about.
In fact, Barry talks about
in the podcast,
he talks about that Sinatra put
a hit on him about three times.
And it went on
for like 50 years.
Finally, these guys were so old,
the hit man Barry talks about --
The hit man
had him in his sights,
and then his colostomy bag
broke, and he missed him,
which I think in the mob,
that's a rite of passage, right,
like, to get to that age
where you have a colostomy bag?
-Because, yeah, it's very hard
to have a long career
in the mob.
So if you can get
to the colostomy bag stage,
that's an accomplishment.
But this is so --
-It's a crazy story.
I mean, it's --
I always pitch it
as, like, you know,
the Marx Brothers meets
the Coen Brothers or something.
But, truthfully, it's about a --
You know, it's about
a mentally ill man.
And being able to do it as a
podcast, it really had the time
to sort of dig into his psyche
and try to figure out
why he did this.
He was at his lowest,
this guy Barry Keenan.
And he was overlooking
Catalina Island,
and he said God --
a voice came over on the radio
and told him to kidnap somebody.
And then he said the radio
wasn't even on.
And his first choice
was going to be Bob Hope's son,
but he thought,
"Oh, that's too patriotic.
I should go for Sinatra's,
you know, kid
because, you know, the mob
and Sinatra's --" you know.
So, the third time he --
His third attempt was the day
that Kennedy got assassinated.
So the whole nation's
like this, right?
Sinatra's like this.
You know his relationship
with the Kennedys.
And he gets up -- He said,
"Well, that's in Dallas.
I got a schedule to keep."
He gets up --
He gets up to Tahoe,
gets Sinatra Jr.,
brings him down the hill,
stashes him
in the valley over here,
and then realizes,
"Oh, man, I left the gun.
I left fingerprints.
I left my fake mustaches.
I got to go back up."
So he asks his girlfriend,
who was a virgin at the time,
to drive him back up.
She gets so turned on,
she has sex with him
when they get there
overlooking the crime scene.
-Sure, who wouldn't? Yeah.
-And he had --
Right, that happens.
-Yeah.
-And he had to --
You know, the FBI was onto him,
so they disguise themselves
as honeymoon skiers.
But in a blink --
At this moment, he's got --
He's the most wanted man
in America.
He's got the FBI,
the CIA, J. Edgar Hoover.
Everyone wanted to --
Sam Giancana called Sinatra
and said, "Let me do it
my way, Frank."
And he's going down
the bunny slopes in Lake Tahoe.
So...
-It is a crazy, crazy story.
And then I guess at the time,
Frank Sinatra
probably didn't know
that you were maybe one day
going to tell this story,
but you got to meet him.
-Yeah.
-This is you and Paula Abdul
and Frank Sinatra.
Where did you see him?
-This was in Orange County,
and I got to bring my family.
I think -- We got to meet him.
I don't think -- Frank was
more of a "Straight Up" --
He was more of a Paula Abdul fan
than mine.
But we called ahead
to see if we could meet him.
And they said, "Well,
if Sinatra wants to meet you,
he'll let you know."
What does that mean?
So, Rickles goes on, and
I didn't know him at the time.
You know, since, I was
very good friends with him,
as you might know,
over the last 15 years.
So, Rickles goes on,
and then it's intermission.
And someone says,
"Mr. Sinatra will meet you now."
So we get to go back. And my dad
was the biggest Sinatra fan,
so it was a really important
moment for me.
We go back, and my mom
had this story for years
that Sinatra tried to hit on her
on her wedding --
on her honeymoon.
And she said, "No, Frank,
I'm a married woman," you know?
So, at this concert she --
First of all, we get backstage,
and she's into a couple drinks.
She beelines towards Frank.
Jilly Rizzo,
who was Frank's guy,
you know, tackles --
grabs my mother.
And I'm like,
"Don't kill my mom!
Let me get a picture of Frank
first, then you can beat her up.
But let's get the picture."
So it was a pretty,
pretty great moment.
And then at the end of the
concert, Rickles comes back out.
You know how they introduce
the celebrities in the audience,
"Oh, Tony Danza, Paula Abdul.
That's John Stamos."
And I was sort of
embarrassed to stand up.
And then, he said, "Oh, he's
probably in the cheap seats.
In fact, he's
probably in the grass.
In fact, he's probably
smoking grass."
And Sinatra grabs the mic
from Rickles
and says,
"Smoke one for me, Johnny."
And I was like, "There we go."
[ Laughter ]
-I also want to talk
about "Big Shot."
This is really exciting.
So, you play sort of
a Bobby Knight-esque coach
who gets kicked out of the NCAA,
goes to coach
an all-girls school.
And one of the really exciting
things about this
is you've been getting very good
critical response to this show,
good critical response
specifically to
your performance.
And I wanted to bring that up
because the last time
you were here, we talked about
how that maybe wasn't the case
with "Fuller House"
and you were kind enough
to let us read you
some of those reviews.
Let's just remind you
real quick.
"Hollywood Reporter" said,
"It's doubtful
that there will be
a more painful 2016 TV episode
than the 'Fuller House' pilot."
-I mean --
[ Audience oohs ]
-"There's a point
where nostalgia becomes
more like necrophilia,
and 'Fuller House'
immediately crosses that line."
"Netflix's 'Fuller House'
is like a porn parody
without the porn."
[ Laughter ]
-That was great!
That was one of my most favorite
talk show moments ever.
We were so good together,
you and I.
We had chemistry.
-We had chemistry.
And, look, you're good
without me, too,
because I just --
I do want to read some of this.
"Entertainment Weekly,"
Kristen Baldwin said,
"Stamos scores
in heartfelt dramedy 'Big Shot,'
delivering dry wit and sweet
sentiment in equal measure."
"Time" magazine,
that's a big one, Judy Berman,
"'Big Shot' a surprisingly
lovable sports drama.
Stamos reliably likeable
and makes it easy to root
for a high-strung bully."
That's great.
"Esquire," another big one,
Brady Langmann, "Stamos gives
one of the most heartfelt
performances of his career."
And -- Oh, son of a gun.
-What? What happened?
-One of the "Fuller House" ones
slipped in here.
-Uh-oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's "New York Times,"
James Poniewozik,
"The series begins
as a sitcom family reunion.
It becomes
a self-conscious, dated,
and maudlin reminder
of the ceaseless march of time
in your inevitable demise."
-So he liked it then?
-I think he liked it, yeah.
We only have that part.
I'm sure he bounced back.
-It was very --
It was alarming, those reviews.
And they weren't fake, either.
And then, yeah, then "Big Shot"
has been just getting
love letters.
It's a David E. Kelly show,
and I'm so proud of it.
And then, you know, we're
on the bubble, as they say.
So, you know, who knows?
-Alright, well, I hope
you get right off that bubble
where you -- I hope you get on
the Rob Lowe side of the bubble,
which is where
we all want you to be.
And thank you so much, John.
It's always a delight
to see you.
-Thank you, Seth. And thank you
very much for having me.
-"Big Shot" is
streaming now on Disney+,
and "Snatching Sinatra"
is available on Wondery
and wherever you get your
podcasts.